la france envahi ces derniers jours par
les citrouilles les sorcières
d'halloween une opération commerciale
rondement mené pour faire accepter cette
fête si typiquement américaine se filmer
l iri giorgio
ici on a pris de l'avancé halloween 99
est déjà en ébullition sous le burin de
ces sculpteurs
surenchère de l'horreur le gore fait son
effet brière d'être le plus monstrueux
possible pour peupler les cauchemars des
fêtards de tous âges ses créateurs là
nous parlent de nos frayeurs les plus
intimes fait deux morts fatalement
s'appelait ça plaît aux amateurs
d'horreur maintenant si on rajoute
quelques petits morceaux de viande par
ci par là pour les perfectionnistes les
puristes pour ajouter un peu plus nous
sommes à semur chez césar le leader
mondial du masque pour cette pme qui
emploie une centaine d'ouvriers dont une
part importante de saisonniers halloween
est une aubaine en trois ans le chiffre
d'affaires des citrouilles sorcières
lucifer et autres vampires s'est établi
à près de 30 millions de francs et c'est
énorme puisqu'on estime le marché
français confiseries et déguisements
confondues à une centaine de millions
halloween est ce arrivé chez nous en
fanfare il y a trois ou quatre ans
propulsée par des gigantesques
d'opérations marketing
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'y met
les bouchons sont des cibles
privilégiées depuis une semaine une
ribambelle de petits monstres
suivent les ateliers du jardin
d'acclimatation une proposition parmi
les centaines qui fleurissent autour du
potiron et de sa légende
ici on fait saliver les gourmets en 1re
l étage c'est barbouillage à volonté il
n'en faut pas plus aux bambins pour
adopter sans retenue cette fête venue
d'ailleurs les grands non plus n'ont pas
mis longtemps à s'y mettre dans cet
entrepôt du 20e arrondissement de paris
l'amicale on propose sur 2000 mètres
carrés 10000 références
ici on peut s'offrir une panoplie
complète pour une centaine de francs
alors pour une fois et pour la bonne
cause
les bourses des nids centraux d'angoise